hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast involvement of biologists
and data analysis requires
visualizations my name is June fam and
from labyrinth and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by kokor glue core is a
bioinformatics company from Sweden that
was founded in 2007 since the starts the
ambition has been to turn the world of
bioinformatics on its head of providing
solutions that are faster and easier to
use the solution is visualization
grumbling laura has clients in 25
countries and they are mainly from the
life sciences and biotech industry for
more information please visit blue core
com we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we're trying to
answer as many questions as we can
giving the largest slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problems through the green
Q&A button lower left this is an
educational web seminar and the scoffers
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over please click on the
cee button located at the bottom left
hand corner of your web page and follow
the process of obtaining your credit I
would like now to introduce today's
speakers Karl Johan Iverson can enter us
puritas Karl Johan I arson has more than
20 years experience from the software
and power communications industry broad
experience from international business
management and sales he is one of
glucose founders and clickers presidents
since 2007
dr. Thomas very attentive is a professor
and senior consultant at the department
of clinical genetics University and
regional laboratories when University an
elected member of several learned in
society and an associate editor of genes
chromosomes and cancer apart from gloom
corps is also a co-founder of kantarjian
baby I will now turn it over to carl
johan iverson for his presentation okay
thank you thank you for the introduction
during the webinar we will send to all
the involvement of virology in the data
analysis has value and new opportunities
and also the discuss the requirements
related to such involvement one part of
the governor will be a live
demonstration of performance explore we
will also share examples on how to
format the store it's been used by our
clients the efforts to develop new drugs
new treatments and understand more about
the biology that drive drive improvement
in equipment methods and techniques as a
consequence complexity and constant
change or always in the modern biology
we will use the term biology in the
meaning of them scientists biologists
chemists medical depth area everybody
that worked with data without having
that as a main task to Elsa and we we
will use do that throughout the webinar
one of the effect is the data analysis
has become too fattening it's not a big
surprise tinta growth in the beyond
somatic field for many years we've been
about 20 different animals I think it
first assume that we are all in
agreement of the amount of data to be
analyzed is really very source and
improve solutions or require to maximize
the outcome of the generated data to
offer to poor and reliance it has been
clear for several years of the solutions
to the ever growing amount of data or
not
only faster computers more holidays for
new address obvious is indeed needed
that it's not not when we meet clients
that commonly communicate that the lack
of analysis resources absorbs knowledge
update development and sells projects
down our solution to these challenges is
to enable data analysis closer to the
data source by involving biologists and
that's the end time this will give
multiple benefits improve use of the
velvety knowledge about the study system
in support first one and most important
one it will then enable new innovations
and solutions through the cross
functional team work that is enabled by
having more confident area is to be
involved in the analysis and having more
groups also enables wreath of balance
and respectability the requirement for
software solutions for biology is the
difference compared to requirements for
buying politicians let's look at a
couple of examples please note that
these examples does not apply to all
individuals in the two groups cover
generalization Tobias magician he or she
works with data analysis at the main top
whereas the biology is doing a lot of
other things to their analysis of the
dark magicians of killed in computers
and software whereas the biologist is
the user of computers fragmentations of
Gilden statistics that where are the
values are basics of this technology
when it comes to biology the right
Leticia has a basic knowledge where the
vault is equipped with the thing that we
need to find solutions that can work
portability poster for the bank magician
I'm for to meet the requirements for the
biology we need a solution that it's
easy to use and learn but also includes
that it should also include the
statistical methods and tools that are
being used and are usable by non-expert
and have guides the more infrequent use
to the next step in the process at the
same time that it doesn't block the use
of more creative analysis and building
on the biologies domain knowledge and
visualization is the solution of a
computer courses we will one what is the
physics will
other with the irrelevant sound we
should be our opinion on locating so to
achieve this we are using three key
elements and visualization is in the
center then it gives a vision and
easy-to-understand feedback to the user
in four sets of the analysis it is
unable to use the best actor recognized
amount of the human brain the click and
point user interface makes it easy to
use you don't have an expiry no
requirements or phone writing code
instead required functionality is only a
few mouse clicks away until gore mukhde
explorer it's very fun it's all still
run and all others who don't work on the
market for advanced visualization this
enables the things that we are striving
for the new binding and the cooperation
between will the possibility to balance
the resources and get the biology people
at this point that we like to highlight
and work like one statement that we
shouldn't make that visualization tool
for with visualization software that
includes the statistics and under tools
for that there are a lot of software
around that denies visualization so they
basically help you to to to make
pictures of things that you already know
whereas if you integrate the Pacific
methods and combine that with
visualizations and do happiness workflow
that is tailored pathologies and you
will be able to do a lot more than that
the sense of interdisciplinary to the
vascular scientists in Boston was
created in 2009 by Brigham and Women's
Hospital and if elephant they are one of
our clients and they have a situation
where they have been lacking the
implementation and
I wanted to do something about that the
latest authority to use people from
explore this was a nation is an
initiative taken by and do such a thing
who gets the procurement food and they
use the latest technologies in math
geometry and work with a lot of
different weasels research field after
their as the temper and what they have
found of the using people for a while
estas Cupid's ball very intuitive and
the gas the user in space is simple to
use it means the pathologist affects the
now do you fundamentals of its analysis
independently having more control of
your data it also means that the science
magicians and total there there if
magicians can concentrate on very
involved I informatics and the wider
frontiers of Pacifica another role as
well form of such a thing you can we
become read more about this case study
and until full of calm we also can read
other cases I will now leave the word
due to the theaters on a people founded
and he will share an example on how we
have been used in through core and can
see we that we thank you very much so i
will give one example of my research
group in the past and currently are
using to work on it explored to identify
new targets on looking at them so in
this project that is currently growing
we start with fresh in this case
zucchini examples and we do yoga gene
expression of malleable so in the past
like when of you we use micro rates but
can't we reform RNA take only we do that
on closed-circuit cell population that
the left can picture you can see when we
take the chemical filtration and then
changed pressure profile so after we
feel later in the light beam over Cooper
on it or it's possible to create
specific gene list for example based on
gene ontology categories or you can make
your in-house curate the gene list and
you can import that software so in this
specification that I'm going up here we
used a cure the gene list of
approximately 1,000 candidate filter the
start that that would be the third
picture up sly and when we use that we
only look for a differential Express
cell surface model because we use that
if a candidate del surface nakajima it
and Annette that we throw away
everything apart from the desert and
then we within a two kilometre explore
software we could compare normal with
Molina and leukemia in that study that
we published a few years ago and we have
also pulled up on that we ended up with
a set of approximately ten genes being
up regulated on the leukemia stem these
genes were of course specifically cancer
and from that list we could then
generate that the borders or you or
order them from commercial suppliers and
defect analysis and we can validate that
tableau be differentially expressed more
crisp indeed were up-regulated also at
the protein level based effect analysis
and what will impact connect we identify
the map marker called I'll one rep that
cancelled before I want emailing with
antibodies we can sort out felt only
expressing the belt surface markers you
can't eat far to the left is the small
figure where we could prove and
demonstrate but only the leukemic cells
that had a specific chemically change in
this case Philadelphia chromosome we're
positive but an orator only then we're
going to generate a molecule
electron land walton later on monitoring
antibodies and we could then demonstrate
in vitro or X people that we could kill
of leukemia stem cells by its science by
antibodies direct to the subset so I
think this shows an example how you do
important biological discoveries quite
easily with the software when you use
biological means that over in the
beginning we have also in the fastest
averaging list works of genius contain
connect with or epigenetic modifiers and
I only focused on the differential
express the nature of the genes or
proteins where we do our dialogical so I
think that concludes that Google almonds
explore can be used at an according to
very specific biological question and to
answer such questions rapidly in a
highly translational research setting
and the pork of this work has been done
mainly biology using this software and
as we heard previously that will speed
up time for our limitations for First
Avenue right back so thank you very much
hand over to cause you wanna do that
again okay thank you do it this now
brings that to the live demonstration we
have talked and that introduced you to
what you can do with officially patients
but now if there are very true to
visualization it's time to actually show
you and so we will work with an example
the data test from or from leukemia and
we will use two different therapist the
second one is actually downloaded from
phoenix person never so that's the way
of using for already public available
information during the demonstration we
will generate new hypotheses by
identifying new sub views and we will in
a second phase
again since I discriminating variable
for known annotation in parallel
visualize the results and the last step
we use the public data that to confirm
the results that we found when we found
identify the discrimination variability
during this demonstration we will only
show more part of available
functionality performance explorer but
hopefully you will be the opportunities
than and do more investigation by role
play 21 yeah but before a start we have
highlight the type of data that you
actually can important work withing 24
next explore and in short it is very
very flexible old models and methods or
generic so you can basically bring in
animal feed arias data and here is a
number of examples the next question DNA
methylation for joking the one hand over
the most generic way to get data into
the program is used with it does take
the whole type of dppc PSD files in
different formats and tells the user to
decide what parts of the parlor to be
appropriate for a number of other types
of data for instance an RNA text we can
support and normalize lines and also
there is a simple and straightforward
worthless okay but that brings me to the
presentation or demonstration here so i
will now change the you should now also
on your screen we should switch from
we'll go back to order demonstrate the
slides here students to the program and
hopefully it's good do them well also at
your place and that's the tpac I get
there so good now we can get started the
first image visualization that you
always get when you open a dataset Inc
economics explore it's a PDF of
principal component analysis we use that
technique because its proximal in the
sense that if you would like to keep the
maximum amount of variation in the data
sets and visual access and in this
example is clear here is one child as
the kingdom and if you look down to the
lair if there's one of 32 e tanto and
then it is twenty two thousand two
hundred and eighty two variables so we
have a date of death with one or 32
samples and 22,200 both yes 4g to check
your variable so James Duthie help you
like that and then they're all
twenty-two thousand small spheres of
that that is really stepped out of this
point is analysis so I will leave that
and go back to the sample the first
thing I would going to do was to use
some of the filters that you can find
here in this specific dialogue to try to
identify and different subgroups in the
data so now I'm going to generate
hypotheses I don't know and because I
have an idea but that should be decent
sup dude but I don't know how many and I
don't know the example that plan to
defeat and to the PT April doesn't give
me any direct indication of the subgroup
and that is because they say that
a lot of noise subunit the planet and
the barrier is doing here can help you
to do that so aya torquay remove
bearable and then the book chapter antes
and you have to show you that removed a
lot of variables yeah talkative
structure in this you can click over and
see that we only have 81 relatively easy
enough it's not here I don't have to
know exactly what 15 touch the fat when
I thought I can just move the slider and
it is really really one of the things
that makes the chronic before you need
because variable I filled the using that
little slider and like the click and
check things are updated the question is
of course how much should you fill the
novel variants and to assist you with
chocolate version you have a method
careful three actions for which tells
you when the PPA projection includes
maximum amount of information so to go
green that's good and the maximum seems
to be open for visitors that's the good
visualization of this to typically
determined that there are no general
guidelines FL evaluated from various
this matter so it's really dependent on
your data type but we can directly see
now that these samples over here seem to
be very closely rules together so that's
indicating that those are one will they
have the expression patterns that are
similar that it works s grouping me and
there seems to be one more group here
and maybe even more guilty so lift tour
based information and we do that for
creating a conversation and since we're
not generating on prophecies why don't
we politic flow
or the color data set according to the
planet asia we select select annotate
dear we just drove to this now i've
divided my data into two groups to have
one on 18 samples in my blue group and
14th up relative i can we eat we remove
that and then i can adjust a little bit
more see where we have our maximum
sometimes encumber early under always
successfully perspective over here and
we have more tools to guide you here we
connect the nearest neighbors we
directly see that there are most active
students back of this Duda and we can
bring the other type of practice leaders
good so till in just a few minutes I
have taught it to generate have profited
on how to divide this data into this
constant loop and this is really a good
approach even if you have care groups in
the data as you would expect because by
doing this as the first step in an
analogous workflow we will make sure
that you don't have any unwanted effects
or batch effect or actually potentially
new things also forces top with an open
mind and that will be very very to that
done that is the first taste of the
analogies generating a hypothesis we
have only used methods that make no
assumptions of the data so sorry are
filtering no punctures and dca know we
have also the option that will show but
you can do k-means clustering generate
globules automatically get an annotation
based on us so we have also undo to life
for generating a profit I will now move
to the second phase of the analysis fear
where I will use the built-in
statistical method to identify
discriminating d first I will look at
the one of the annotation that was
loaded with the database it is fully
teaming a subtype and if I caramel
editor if you like this so this is an
annotation created by the position to
visit study using different techniques
and this data test to to classify data
here we have seven different countries
we are take away one of the groups so
that you see how easy it is to make work
with subset of the data path and then i
will use for the parables that can
discriminate one of the sub do i select
our fear in my pacific dialogue and i
will select the blue one the TL am at
one and i take it to group comparison
which is a student t-test since it is
one bill that they will have to test
work for a lot of fun and I could have
selected multiple comparison which is a
nova or different type of regression if
I'm not pleased with the pink bill in
being specific method I can also go to
the extenders out here and store to use
the open API that we supplied water or
but then you can write to fold the
physical sense even or please watch but
already available at north but we still
use the built-in and very force
then instead of moving my Baron slider
and you prove the p value or Q value
capital slider and what is very
important is that you see the immediate
update of the TPA o'clock you see
directly what is happening but you are
separating house lesbian I'm a group of
the other and you have your forces
cabaret directly calculated here and
you'd be down to the left but you have
140 state variables if you would like to
combine a p-value castle which one is
that the fold change you can do that by
us are moving south tomorrow say around
two now we find 97 variable plus at the
fold change of 2 and Q value of 5 to the
power of my face the vari-epp I've only
showed you the PPA plot so for but let
me also introduce you to the heat map
and we can configure that so I will now
show and we'll take it according to you
Tamia sub sighs of course this of them
upregulated genes for sis pln one dude
and here we have for the others at
random we can order it according to
cross the crackling and whistling for
students and those third all tight on
time to time and the good thing is that
this is also through the dynamic flow so
we find out will change my filtering
everything is we just like this and
updated as I do like that it's changing
my variables if I would change one of my
remove a couple of good everything is
also half days
so that is the true flexibility and
interactivity that is different from at
the store provides to the penalty let's
see we should have it may be something
around 100 wearable so here I don't have
my 100 orders of the best of
discriminating the TNA my love to if I
would like to do all those variables
they are actually so we're here in what
people automatically hope you can I will
see there are 90 days if I change does
not also changes and to store that
wisdom I ask make a copy of it and I
have it here and then I can populate
that with back gene symbols and Q value
that is available in this column as well
with important information about how the
list was great deal with specifics of
the fuse will use the first place as
before and this information and them is
an easily exported you can export it as
images for you can explore with us
variability
the tennis another important flow type
is the books doctor that will allow
let's show you yeah very very pleased to
hear i'm sure it'll quickly that's done
my leukemia subside and then on my
y-axis by selectively for one of them
are you get us close by here another
catastrophe and again think i would
simply something the thirties updated
everything is a place beyond which I'll
selected and if i go back now to my heat
map here it is both updated and I can
continue than all of the tooth you never
have to reconfigure anything it's just a
left as it was the last time you work
with it it is very very efficient and if
an i will talk to nobody else is there
to 30 Cal lab group and go to magic map
then what do business here affect us
back to Madras plus it really saves a
lot of time to have a respectability
building I printed my list here of 109
where are those that will get a similar
separating the dlp milligram will
explore the other groups in the data set
I will now open a second database the
one that I had used them download
functionality from gene expression
omnibus but I've already done that so
that we don't have to wait for proteins
Annette and this is another leukemia
rate of death and we can have a look
there is the 190 samples and since 2000
variables there are a number of
annotations here that one is more
interesting than the other and that is
where we have the different subside i
will now color and falling
to that and in the same way as we don't
on our data separated the T ALL maybe a
little bit on to Humble here and a
separate the different from the others
the ba ll tops and a bright cloud now we
use a functionality into coming to tour
the control and the base data analysis
on the list so instead of using my
filters here is to select variables I
will face the analysis normal asleep and
this is the least acceptable generative
with my earlier data section I will
validate that by selecting the best
interest this to this data and what do
we see it seems like these 109 tonsils
pairs of jeans really separate these
yellow sample fear from the rest with
some exceptions are very clearly see
patterns the CLL are still separated but
also for social separating of the yellow
so let's go back to the annotation and
look for the yellow door they are all
BLK male 1 there is also one for fear
pls so now with this i can conclude that
the least expected in my first day that
have actually behaved from a biological
point of view in a similar expected way
in my second base order to have
validated my loose ass and pull in Hinna
in a few minutes using a publicly as a
little later fest downloaded this
awesome so that brings me to the end
here of the live demonstration and i
will go back to be
Clive dear so when you're in the short
demo and I would like to give you a
couple of examples of how it can be
implemented in different organizations
and work is most important and i will
start with the example of academia will
be dilated other standing still dances
this is typically with it ok then the
soap is is quite wide where you don't
both to build exploration and analysis
you work with many types of data the
public data is like geo and working with
a built-in tagine set enrichment
analysis works on that we have used in
there and also a batch directions or
important bottom ultimately you would
like to do is to point where you can do
a publication in peer reviewed your
knowledge evening image it we're in
typically if your former company this
bill bit a little bit smaller for inking
that the aspect of dubrovnik destroyed
more on exploration and hypothesis
generation there might be stronger
bye-bye ematic support so that you can
work with three process data where we
have a knife formats such as been doing
enough from databases and so on and of
course the public data aspect is still
important and we have a low points that
before for sharing and keeping track so
before what they've been doing that is
really like that laptop of the program
that you can go back to which is very
powerful and of course will explore to
itself is equally important company so
to summarize before we open up there for
Q&A that I have a few slides but thanks
for lists watching so far and again to
grow my sixth floor is for everybody or
absence as the lessons of angry
checkboxes slider from above
it is really for explosive analysis and
much more than night with some reporting
or nice visualization sensors in big
statistics the user is always in full
control we really do to disable to do
any different visual and instant update
on all your ass action it is for really
for different users patterns you can be
an expert if you want the music every
day but it is also easy to learn and
it's to remember so you can use it more
frequently the question is will it be
working your organization of course if
you go to to preform and look at the
references page you will be well over
300 publications from our clients that's
already using it in their setting so
that is good example and the if you
continue to and drop round to preform
you with the case studies and and the
suitability to download a free trial and
watch movies similar to go find our
childhood here today so and we take good
care of time the customers and we're
happy to have you both during a trial
and undergrowth later on so that is my
last slide here and be happy to open up
for questions
okay thank you so much for that
informative presentation that was
excellent so before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience of house it's and
the questions you can submit questions
by typing them in the Q&A box which can
be found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window try to answer as
many questions as we can sit in okay um
your first question because just glue
court omics explore require any special
hardware yeah thank you for the question
no it doesn't really it works both
negatively built on the windows and mac
and it gave very very well so you can
use it also on with big data set on
quite weak computers great thank you
okay next we have a white question from
Randy who asked in a core lab setting
does the core lab host to software or
does the customer or biologists have the
software and how portable are the
results okay that was like three
question p 1 thank you and there this
software is a client software and so
that will always run on the local
machine of the user but a for the
licenses there are two options either
you can have individual in goleta
licenses or you can work with floating
licenses so typically from lab setting
you will work with loathing licenses
that limits the number of current users
it's been a very cost efficient solution
but all biologists can have the
programming tool and then I will only
use the license whether actually
analyzing data the stick and halt fear
of the question was how portable or the
results and we are all exports or images
or standard image formats and all
exports that escape space or tab
separated text file and which means that
we is truly portable sounds great and
next we have a question from a
participant who asked Kim more than one
user in my organization use a trial
version yes the trial version can be
used by aslam a used as you would like
in a specific organization they are done
of love to an organization
fantastic next another user wants to
know is some the software works on RNA
seek data yet is that you can either
come in with a pre normalized data and
importance during using a wizard then
you have your numbers and you are
performing and using all the techniques
that I showed you in the demonstration
or if you have aligned BAM files we can
also help you with the normalization and
import subtype that directly to very
interesting thank you and then another
participant was to know how fast does
the software or house how can your
software we so fast yeah I think it's a
combination of several things that is
really a selection of methods that are
optimal to to be quick and then we have
made a lot of effort in making us and
writing the code in a way that Pacific
so both very interesting and next we
have a question from your own grass is
nonparametric statistics also available
yes through the the open and the
extended statistics but I showed very
very briefly there are a nonparametric
statistical tests available we will then
run them in also you will have to have
work are installed on the computer but
the methods that tasks were already
integrated and shipping with the
standard program so well we'll put them
on CD and then thank you fantastic come
so if there are no more questions of
morality I would like to once again
thank Carl young man iverson into a
spearhead toast further presentation do
you have any final comments for us
before we leave again thank you very
much for watching and i hope to give the
possibility to come to you with some
other location and under the state and
please be free to download and flied out
in your own organization if you have any
questions just go to to correspond press
contact I will be happy to support well
thank you so much we love having you I
would also like to thank our sponsor
record making today's educational
webcast possible and today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through November of 2016 you will
receive an email from leverett's
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay mean by new to
fourth I announcement to your colleagues
Hume and miss today's love is it that's
all we have for Tim thank you for
participating and we hope to see you
again next time